[Musica]
un giorno nella foresta scoppia un
grande incendio e tutti gli animali
spaventati e terrorizzati iniziano
andare verso le rive del fiume iniziano
tutti a pensare a cosa fare mentre solo
un piccolo colibrì guarda l'incendio e
poi guarda il fiume riguarda l'incendio
e poi riguarda il fiume e lo fa una due
tre dieci volte
poi decide di prendere una piccola
goccia d'acqua e lamette sull'incendio
prende un'altra goccia d'acqua e lamette
sull'incendio alla vista di tutto questo
il leone lo ferma e gli dice ma scusa
che stai facendo
e lui risponde non lo vedi sto provando
a spegnere un incendio
ovviamente iniziarono tutti a deriderlo
ma lui non curante di tutto questo
prendo una piccola goccia d'acqua e la
getta sul fuoco ecco io mi sento un po
così quando parto per le missioni
umanitarie
mi sento un piccolo colibrì che
trasporta una piccola goccia d'acqua e
l'ha gettato un incendio
vorrei solo per pochi minuti farvi
entrare in quella che è stata la mia
prima missione umanitaria
vengo trascinato quasi a forza da mia
moglie da quella che diventerà dopo due
anni mia moglie noi ci conosciamo da
dieci anni quindi tra noi basta uno
sguardo e mi fido di lei e decido di di
assecondare questa sua scelta che ci
faccio io un chirurgo plastico in
missione con tutti quei bambini che a
malapena so come sono fatti conosco
malapena l'altezza e mi riecheggiano le
parole di un nostro collega che ci
diceva attenzione non è una passeggiata
non è una passeggiata preparatevi
facciamo i biglietti con i primi
risparmi dopo la laurea e partiamo
affrontiamo il viaggio 14 ore di volo
ma questa volta ad aspettarci non c'è un
resort c'è un
una stanza senza luce e senza acqua
corrente piena di insetti e non ci
sentiamo proprio al nostro agio iniziamo
a ripulire tutto quanto e dopo venti
minuti ci mettiamo a dormire direi
finalmente dopo circa una mezz'oretta c
bussano alla porta e ci chiedono di
andare in medicheria perché un
giardiniere aveva preso un pugno a
livello del volto e andava strutturato
quindi andavano messi dei punti apriamo
le nostre valigie prendiamo tutto
l'occorrente prendiamo le torce perché
dobbiamo strutturare al buio prendiamo
gli anestetici e superiamo il
giardiniere e torniamo tutti quanti a
dormire e vi starete chiedendo cosa c'è
di strano in tutto questo il giorno dopo
il giardiniere
immaginate davanti alla nostra stanza fa
un cuore gigante con tutte le foglie che
trova e con tutta la terra del terreno e
ci fornisce tutta questa composizione
con dei fiori
ovviamente io e valentina rimaniamo
stupiti da questa cosa ci sentiamo un
pochettino più a casa
ma la cosa più assurda e lo continuo a
fare il giorno dopo giorno dopo ancora
il giorno dopo ancora e lo fa per altri
10 giorni
alla fine gli ho colpito da questa cosa
a mio modo deciso di ringraziarlo che
faccio
dietro a 5 dollari e vi starete
chiedendo cosa c'è di male in tutto
questo passano due giorni e mi
richiamano dalla direzione del posto e
mi dicono claudio pur sapendo la
risposta per caso hai dato dei soldi a
giardiniere io sì perché il giardiniere
venne licenziato perché fu trovato
ubriaco in città e si spese tutti i
soldi in birre
solo allora mi resi conto di avergli
regalato tutto insieme la somma
equivalente di un anno di lavoro dieci
volte quello che guadagnavo al mese
inutile dirvi che mi sono sentito in
colpa mi sono sentito in colpa perché
perché probabilmente lui non era pronto
a ricevere emotivamente questa somma di
denaro e io pensavo di fare una cosa
giusta invece avevo sbagliato
i giorni successivi ho iniziato a
riflettere su che cosa non bisogno le
popolazioni che andiamo ad aiutare
durante le nostre missioni umanitarie e
mi sono detto non hanno bisogno dei
nostri soldi
sembra assurdo ma non hanno bisogno dei
nostri soldi hanno bisogno sicuramente
delle nostre competenze hanno bisogno
sicuramente delle nostre esperienze
hanno bisogno sicuramente delle nostre
vite dei nostri cuori che portiamo in
missione e che portiamo nelle loro
culture attenzione i soldi sono
importanti e servono per fare le
missioni umanitarie ma noi dobbiamo
integrare la nostra cultura con la loro
senza cambiarla non dobbiamo avere
questa presunzione ma la cosa più
importante che dobbiamo renderli liberi
e quindi dobbiamo dargli una ricchezza e
questa ricchezza di renderli liberi da
che cosa dalla schiavitù dalla schiavitù
di che cosa dalla schiavitù di dover
chiedere e quindi dover dipendere da
qualcuno
quando sono diventato papà
nei confronti delle mie figlie mi sono
ripromesso solo una cosa
questo di renderle libere mi sono
ripromesso di non fare le cose al posto
loro
mi sono ripromesso di star lì a guardare
sorvegliando i loro errori
perché un giorno non ci sarò più spero
più tardi possibile
ma mi immagino così le popolazioni che
andiamo ad aiutare noi andiamo in
missione e quando ce ne andiamo
loro restano sole con i loro problemi a
meno che non abbiamo generato competenze
e non li abbiamo resi liberi
molto spesso mi viene detto beh club
tu sei un chirurgo per te è normale
partire per te è facile fare questa
scelta
ma io li che faccio questa oltre ad
essere una bella scusa permettetemi di
dirlo è anche una grossa bugia perché
noi nella prima missione che non avevamo
le competenze che adesso nel tempo
abbiamo sviluppato quindi io per esempio
ho sviluppato le mie competenze
chirurgiche che però le o acquisite
durante tutte le missioni quindi questo
è un passaggio successivo nella prima
missione ci siamo anche divertiti a
cambiare i pannolini
il mio primo pannolino no cambiato in
missione abbiamo giocato a biliardino
con i ragazzi ho cucinato
considerate che in italia questa cosa io
lo odio il mio piatto forte la pasta in
bianco
il parmigiano valentina lo sa e da lì
l'idea che ognuno di noi ha un talento
segreto nascosto che però ha l'obbligo
morale di trovare di scoprirlo quindi e
di metterlo al servizio degli altri
ognuno può fare qualcosa basta voler
farlo basta agire invece che stare
seduti a guardare tutto dall'esterno una
cosa importante che dico sempre è che il
viaggio di ritorno delle missioni è un
momento bellissimo
è un momento che io prendo per me spesso
avviene in aereo un momento che
custodisco all'interno del mio cuore
dove rifletto scusate su tutto quello
che è successo in missione e mi scorrono
davanti le immagini dei bambini che
corrono e ci credano dicendoci monde le
monde le modelle vuol dire bianco nella
loro lingua e bianco ha un'accezione
discriminatoria ma discriminatoria in
senso positivo questa volta positivo
perché bianco è associato a speranza
bianco è associato a chance
io aggiungo bianco andrebbe associato a
competenza e quindi a nuove opportunità
a nuove possibilità non lo nego in
missione
mi sono fatto parecchi pianti perché una
parte di me si sente perennemente in
colpa per essere nato in questa parte di
mondo dove ovviamente non ho nessun
merito in questo siamo nati con le carte
giuste e qui abbiamo solo l'obbligo di
giocarle al momento giusto
credo da sempre che gli altri sono la
nostra ricchezza più grande e cresciamo
sotto le ali dei nostri genitori
giochiamo con i nostri fratelli che
regalo grosso vi hanno fatto i genitori
donandovi un fratello una sorella
giochiamo con i nostri amici
facciamo esperienze con loro viviamo sui
nostri compagni ma soprattutto riviviamo
geneticamente nei nostri figli è una
cosa meravigliosa e probabilmente se
anche voi siete qui ad ascoltare questi
temi anche voi minima parte pensate che
anche gli altri sono più grossa risorsa
ma a proposito siete curiosi di sapere
come è finita la storia del colibrì
ve lo dico lo stesso beh alla vista di
tutto alla vista di tutto questo alla
lista di quanto il colibrì si era
attivato un piccolo elefantino che stava
sotto le ali protettive della madre
inizia a pensare dentro di sé beh io ho
la mia competenza specifica io ho una
proboscide sicuramente posso prendere
molta più acqua rispetto al colibrì
quindi prende l'acqua dal fiume e la
getta sopra un cespuglio e il cespuglio
magicamente si spegne alla vista di
tutto questo anche un pellicano rifletto
sul fatto che lui al becco ma
soprattutto che può volare prende
l'acqua e sorvola l'incendio e getta
all'acqua da sopra quindi aggiunge
competenze altre competenze insieme
fanno una cosa diversa
alla vista di tutto questo tutti gli
animali iniziano a lottare ciascun per
sé ma soprattutto il grande smettono di
deriderli mettono da parte divisioni
millenari e iniziano a lottare fianco a
fianco per spegnere l'incendio
inutile che ve lo dico in poche ore
l'incendio viene spento e tutti iniziano
a festeggiare e alla visita di tutto
questo
il leone chiama il piccolo colibrì
colibrì vieni qua oggi da te abbiamo
imparato una cosa importante
abbiamo imparato che una piccola goccia
d'acqua può servire a spegnere un grande
incendio ma soprattutto abbiamo imparato
che non è non c'è bisogno di essere
grandi e forti per le grandi cose ma
bisogna essere umili e pieni di
generosità abbiamo imparato che le cose
si pensano da soli ma si risolvono tutti
quanti insieme e per me la più grossa
bugia di sempre è la frase che dice
siamo tutti utili e nessuno
indispensabile
no non è vero siamo tutti unici
irripetibili e non per questo possiamo
essere sostituiti
[Musica]